All the NASA lies have to stop. We have
to expose this stuff and we cannot keep
buying into the the the deception, but
so many people are just eating it up. I
want to show you guys some clips
starting with before the launch, in the
rocket, and once they're in space. In
space. And you're going to see all the
deception along the way. Check this out.
Donald Trump NASA's back.
Tomorrow this mission's going off. The
127th mission to the space station. Mike
and Sonya are the two of [music] the
four American astronauts that are on
that flight. They're right out of
central casting. Like they're right out
of central casting. Right out of central
casting. What is central casting? Just
Google this. Central Casting is the
leading casting company in the United
States specializing in supplying
background actors, stand-ins, and photo
doubles for film, television, and
commercial productions. How do you cast
an astronaut for a mission? You don't
cast people for a a a mission that you
could die on. It's not about casting,
it's about training, right? How tall is
Artemis 2? Artemis 2 is coincidentally
ft tall. 322. There are no accidents
when it comes to these elitists. They're
obsessed with numerology. 322 is not a
coincidence. It is the Skull and Bones
secret society that George Bush and John
Kerry were a part of. 322 is their
number. These elitists just have to
constantly throw up hand signs, throw it
up their numerology, and it's over and
over. If you think that's just a reach,
a coincidence, how many astronauts are
Freemasons? And it says at least 10 to
13 American astronauts are known known
to be Freemasons. And if you scroll down
and click this Scottish Rite website,
you scroll through and they're going to
tell you John Glenn Jr. 33 degree. Buzz
Aldrin, he was a 33 degree. Leroy Gordo,
33.
So notice I'm I'm pointing out the
number 33 because these are Freemasons.
33 is a very significant number. It's
the highest level of Freemasonry that
that they make you aware of anyway. Buzz
Aldrin actually took he took a Masonic
flag to the moon supposedly. And check
this out. Is this a coincidence? What is
this What is this V actually? What's the
purpose actually do? It looks like
there's a little buckle here.
I'm not seeing anything buckled into it.
There's just this random V. Is it just
for fashion? Is it
Does it do anything because it looks
awfully similar to what the Freemasons
wear.
Could be a coincidence, but remember a
lot of these guys are Freemasons. And it
says that the watches of NASA Artemis 2
mission X-33 Speedmaster X-33 is the
watch worn by Artemis.
Omega X-33 Speedmaster NASA watch worn
by Artemis. When you look up 33 ft,
you're going to see all these articles
saying NASA shooting for the moon and it
says closer than 33 ft to the stage. Uh
here we go again or 33 ft. How how many
times can this show up? 33 33 ft to the
stage. 33 ft. Over and over 33 ft to the
stage. It says right here 3.3
What's it say? 2 in no heavier than So
it's talking about some Artemis 2 crew
packs a little piece of home for their
space trip. I didn't click the article
to see what this is, but it says no
heavier than 3.3 lbs.
Over and over in these articles. No
heavier than 3.3 lbs. The spacecraft
will carry 3.3 lbs of water. Okay.
Over and over 3.3 of all numbers. Not 3
lbs, but 3.3
lbs. Let's make sure we get it right. 33
over and over 33. Artemis 2 3.3 million
lbs. I looked that up. 3.3 million lbs
of thrust. Okay, it's how much thrust.
So 3.3 lbs of water, 3.3 million lbs of
thrust. Is this all coincidence? Am I Am
I just nuts? Am I Jim Carrey from the
number 23? This is This is NASA's
official website right here. Artemis.
Habitable space 330 cubic ft. 33 again.
33 over and over. How It just happens to
be So 3.3 lbs of water, 3.3 million lbs
of thrust, 330 cubic ft of room
habitable vol habitable volume. I hope
you guys are getting this. This is not
just a coincidence, okay? Would these
guys throw up a hand sign? I mean, if
they threw up a hand sign, wow, that
would just be like another cherry on
top, right? Well, here's the official
NASA YouTube channel. You click play.
And
look, and I have not watched hours and
hours of this footage.
I haven't. All this footage is like 10
hours long. I'm just barely skimming in
this stuff and catching this stuff. And
here you see the guy with 33. I know
he's number three and he's got it on him
twice, but it's just ironic that he
walks by with his 33. She doesn't have a
number. It's just ironic. I'm sure you
guys have seen the picture going around.
This dude that's helping the astronaut
pack something in his sleeve has a demon
face tattooed on his hand and a bunch of
runes on his fingers. Now, I get it.
NASA's just hiring people. This guy he
can he can tattoo whatever he wants on
his hands, but I just think it's really
sus, you know, that everybody that has
to do with this corporation has like a
patch that looks like an upside-down
goat head or you name your ships after
Greek gods and the people that are
helping you load up literally have a
demon on their hand along with some
runes, demonic satanic runes. This
little symbol here is called the winged
sun disc and this is from a website
called egyptiantours.com.
It's not some conspiracy theory website,
but it's talking about this Egyptian
god, what this symbol means. You see
it's a sun disc with the wings and it
has to do with Ra and Horus or the sun,
sun worship. And I just think it's
pretty ironic that they have this logo
right there on their patch, right there
on their chest. Same symbol, the disc
with the wings. Like how much of this
can be a coincidence? Somebody was
watching me and I get it. I got it a
tattoo of an inverted star from back
when I was gothic and everything. But if
somebody was watching me and I
constantly threw up a hand sign or had
some kind of Egyptian symbol behind me
or I I was always talking about how hey,
I just lost 33
lbs or, you know, I had to do a 33
question quiz. If I was always saying
33, always had Egyptian symbols, naming
my cat some Greek god, this would be
suspect, right? Like people would start
calling you out on it. Now check this
out. And again, this is NASA's official
website. Something strange came out of
the rocket. Now I watched. How did these
people get to the top of the rocket?
They took an elevator. From what I saw,
they took an elevator. Maybe I didn't
see the whole thing, but check this out.
>> of Artemis 2 now bound for the moon.
What is that?
>> Humanity's next great voyage begins.
Okay. If you missed it, I'm going to
play it again. The crew of Artemis 2 now
bound for the moon.
>> escape pods?
>> Humanity's next great voyage begins.
>> Remember there's four people on this
mission.
And here we see four
zipline cars going.
They're even numbered 1 2 3 4.
And this is in slow mo. You can see how
slow the rocket's going up. So it's just
like a magician, right? Like look at
this hand. Look at this hand. And while
you're looking at that hand, something's
going on over here. Well, everybody's
paying attention to this rocket because
they just watched astronauts get inside
the rocket.
And now they're waiting for this long
countdown to happen. And finally, now
their attention is on the rocket. And
there's smoke and there's fire.
And while that's happening, four
ziplines are moving.
I got questions, guys.
>> [music]
>> Is this not suspect? Come on.
What is going on, [music] man?
I hope you guys don't just think this is
blowing things out of proportion. This
is serious stuff right here. Now here's
I could show you from the official NASA
website, but I thought it'd be
interesting to get, you know, somebody
else's perspective who's watching the
rocket. And of course, the rocket's
going up, but oh no, it's going
horizontal
and it's starting to go downward.
How come a rocket that's supposed to be
going straight to space? I talked about
this on another video.
The shortest distance between two places
is a straight line.
So if you're going to go to the moon
from Earth, you would find
the moon and you would take a straight
route to it. And people are going to
say, "Oh, you don't understand science.
You have to fly around the the whole
world really fast to get enough speed to
pop out of the atmosphere." It's
ridiculous the things that we're
believing, the things that we're being
told that we just swallow up. And so in
this video, just look at this guy's
he's got one string sitting up, one
string is relaxing on his
chest here
until right about now
when it comes alive and starts bouncing
around
like some puppet
on a string.
I'll back it up right here.
So it's resting on his chest
and suddenly it's alive. It's alive.
What is happening to this string? Why is
it waving and bouncing around?
I got questions, guys. What do you think
about this? Look at this dude's
shirt.
Why is his shirt
lifting up?
I mean, I even see something going on
with his shoulders here.
Looks like harness type stuff or what's
going on with this? What is that?
It literally looks like this is a movie.
He's got a harness and they're trying to
remove
and then he says something right here.
He's saying something to this guy.
And then this guy's like, oh oh okay.
And he turns off the camera. You'll see
his hand reach up and turn the camera
off.
Here we go.
Boom. Turn the camera off.
Why would you ever turn the camera off?
This is you're supposed to be convincing
us that you are going to space, going to
the moon
and you're turning the camera off. So
how are things floating around? Easily.
How do I wear How does a Snapchat give
me
hair and sunglasses when it's on a live
video?
It's all just CGI. You really start to
see that when you watch when you pay
attention to things. Look at this bag.
This is a bag of food. For one, I don't
know why he's not like pushing it out of
his face because
>> been rehydrated [clears throat]
already. So we added water to it and the
shrimp soaked back up the water and it's
actually pretty tasty. It's coming so
close to his eye. Like why didn't he
just push it out of the way?
But watch the corner.
Do Do you see that?
All right.
Here's a corner. You see the corner. Now
that corner goes literally into his
flesh and disappears.
It doesn't bounce off of his head. It's
going through his flesh
because this is CGI.
And you can even see his eyebrow. Watch
his eyebrow just disappear.
Check this out.
Look his eye You see his eyebrow? Look
skin
eyebrow coming back.
Sorry, it's a loading. I don't know why
it's doing that. But look at that. Skin
eyebrow.
You might say that's, you know, bad
pixelation or something, but you can't
deny that this food is coming so close
to his face. Why didn't he just swat it
out of his way? But it's literally going
through his
forehead.
There's no denying that.
Then you'll notice
So you see this red dot on the bag,
right?
And I don't know why it would disappear
at some point
but it does.
I don't understand that because if it's
a 3D model, I don't
understand why the uh dot would
disappear, but one side has a white
label. We're flying up here in space and
those are green dots. But the red dot's
not there.
>> The red dot's not there.
And it's
back right here.
Where is it?
Where's the red dot?
We do have to eat our vegetables even in
space, but don't worry, they do give us
mac and cheese. Interesting stuff here,
guys. This one is my all-time favorite,
so I hope you guys stuck around for
this.
Watch this ball. Now it's not casting a
shadow on her leg and you might think,
well, maybe it's not hovering over her
leg. But if her hands were to grab that
ball
and you could see the shadow of her hand
on her leg
then you should be able to see the ball,
correct?
If she's holding the ball and you see
her hands shadow on her leg
then the ball should cast a shadow as
well, right? Well, when she lets go of
the ball, there's no shadow. Check it
out.
She's holding the ball, you see the
shadow of her hands.
Hands move away.
The ball leaves no shadow.
If you see the shadow of her hands
holding the ball
you would see the shadow of the ball. I
hope that makes sense.
I'll play it again.
No shadow
from the ball alone.
Why? Because this is augmented reality.
This is so easy to do and yet we just
put so much trust in these people. Now
this one
some people may overlook this, but I I
think body language is very important.
And remember when they asked the the
astronauts who went to the moon the
first time in '69 did they see any
stars? They got very uncomfortable.
And one of them said um
yeah, I don't know I don't remember
seeing any stars, putting my eyes
through the optics or whatever. And the
other guy was like, I don't I don't
remember seeing any. And he's just like,
whoa man. Like he looks so
uncomfortable. He's like, shut up, man.
Um then there's another video where I
saw Don Pettit and and another guy and
they're going, oh yeah, you can see all
kinds of stars and planets and Milky
Ways. You can see everything out here
all the time.
Now listen to this. They hate being
asked, can you see the stars? They hate
the question and makes them
uncomfortable and you can see the
discomfort on all their faces.
>> can you still see stars in outer space?
Okay.
Look at the body language, guys.
Look at the body language. As soon as he
asked, watch her face get it so
uncomfortable. I wonder, can you still
see stars in outer space?
Yeah, I was actually just talking to my
crewmates about that today. I've
definitely seen stars in outer space and
I was saying I haven't as many as I
thought I would, so
Now did you see this guy?
Watch this guy's body language.
He says
shut your mouth, give me the microphone
and I'll tell the lie.
Watch this. Watch his lips.
definitely seen stars in outer space and
I was saying I haven't as many as I
thought I would, so Reed
Why did he do that?
Why would you do that?
I I that's not a na That's not any kind
of normal reaction for me. I don't do
that.
This is a code and he's saying do not
answer the question, I got it. And
immediately he's like, why why can't
this guy answer the question? Why can't
he say, well, when the sun is hitting
Earth and the moon, there's too much
light pollution, we can't see the stars.
Instead he's like,
yeah, let me pass it off to my friend
here. I haven't as many as I thought I
would, so Reed
So Reed? Reed, we have so much
illumination from the sun on the moon
and the Earth right now. It's It is hard
at times to see stars, just like when
you walk out in the daytime, you see a
blue sky but no stars. All right, guys.
I got questions.
Like from beginning to end, there are
things They They came from central
casting, looked like they exited out of
a zip line. Then we're seeing that the
rocket actually goes out somewhere into
the ocean, I guess. Then you're starting
to see these
augmented reality things going through
their face, a dot disappearing on the
bag, the little ball not leaving a
shadow, not able to answer a simple
question like, can you see stars at
night? All four of them should have been
able to answer the question, can you see
stars in the sky?
All right, guys. I got questions. I hope
this was eye-opening to you. If it was,
please give this video a thumbs up.
Really helps this video get out into the
algorithm. Right now, so many people are
waking up. I love seeing the comments on
all the official NASA stuff where most
of the reactions are laughing emojis.
People are not buying this stuff
anymore. Help wake up the sleeping
giant. Give this video a thumbs up. If
you would like to support this ministry,
you can do so by going to
candidtruth.org. We got Cash App, Venmo,
Zelle, PayPal. You can also get some
really cool merch on our website. It
really helps to support this ministry.
If you've been giving to this ministry,
we cannot thank you enough. We try to
send a message back to everyone that
gives us a donation, but we some some of
them like Zelle and Cash App won't let
us give you a message, but we see you.
We thank you. We love you. We cannot do
this without you and we will see you
next time on Candid Truth.